[Musique]
bonjour kl indique mail vastine dropsy
stars tentent aujourd'hui de 58 ans j'ai
mon restaurant s'appelle le ix e créole
[Musique]
je suis rentré dans la cuisine par une
grippe a pas envie c'est par obligation
parce que j'avais besoin de sous dans
les parents et pas beaucoup de choses
donc je suis rentré quand même un aide
cuisinier dans le restaurant est
aujourd'hui
depuis cinq ans j'ai mon restaurant lieu
créole j'adore le travailler avec les
des produits anciens comme l'on tente
comme
posez les le grand mère le grand père je
travaille des produits frais déjà mon
carré poulet aux a bien remarqué pc avec
pat qu'être lisier coeur tout je fais
les roues gagnant gagnant autant contre
au plus maintenant mongai
la serviette hong a cédé ses engagements
rue briet on devait pas tort voilà je
suis quelqu'un de
dur est passé pas si la vidéo dure parce
que j'aime bien montrer demain fait
j'aime bien mon travail sans gaspillage
une belle épopée tendance et qu'est ce
que j'arriverai que je dis à ces super
c'est bien c'est formidable exane de
retard
moi mon but aujourd'hui c'est de former
les bonhommes quand les bonnes à marier
chez moi et savent pas cuisiner et sont
contents de reprendre ma cuisine parce
que les sens que c'est une cuisine
raffinée
c'est une cuisine longtemps comme du
zénith à l'heure
[Musique]